these people are systematically
oppressed by their own government
we've been waking up to horrific stories
every day heartbreaking images
separating mothers from their children
they live in a police state where
they're monitored by one of the most
advanced and intrusive surveillance
systems in the world we imagine that the
police force you to stand in front of
the camera for biometric data collection
every online activity is tracked imagine
that the police force you to install
spying tap on your phone their religion
is restricted many traditional Muslim
names are even banned for newborns party
officials are frequently attacking Islam
as very old fashioned very backward
these are some of the suspected
detention camps where an estimated 1
million Regas are held many of them have
not been heard from since being detained
we Gazzara turkic-speaking Muslim
minority in China living mostly in the
sensitive frontier province of Xinjiang
it's more than four times the size of
Germany and borders eight countries it's
home to some 11 million weekers but
because of immigration from the rest of
the country today nearly half of
shingen's population is Han China's
dominant ethnic group narita Kell grew
up in Shenzhen a Weger now living in
America he campaigns against the
oppression of his people but speaking
out against China can be dangerous
I worry my public advocacy will cause
some unthinkable consequences to my
family members I haven't seen my mother
for 15 years this is the mildest form of
torture that the Chinese government is
imposing on us the Communist Party seems
determined to crush Weger identity and
is going about it in a systematic way
although China has long been suspicious
of the wiggers as it has been of many
minority groups its worries increased
after al-qaeda's attack on America on
9/11 after 9/11 the Chinese government
taken an opportunistic position claiming
they are also a victim of global
terrorism in the minds of the party
leaders who IGAs are different and
different is bad because the control of
the Communist Party is the only thing
that stands between China and total
chaos in addition to that there have
been outbreaks of terrorism so there was
a sense that Shinji yang especially was
getting out of control and needed to be
brought back in life in 2014 a group of
weaker terrorists went on a stabbing
rampage in Kunming railway station
killing 31 people this was one of
several attacks that fueled the
government's hostility towards the
weakest the Chinese government Lycans we
were too cancerous tumour Newbery islam
as a mental illness relations between
Wiggins and Han Chinese in Xinjiang have
been tense for years an eruption of
violence in 2009 led the Chinese
government to step up security but it
wasn't until she Jing ping came to power
that China really tightened its grip on
the wiggers
between 2012 and 2017 China's domestic
security budget doubled in Xinjiang it
tripled in 2016
xi Jinping appointed Chen Chen war as
the party secretary of the province this
was a calculated move to suppress the
wiggers Chen Franco is a hand-picked
official trusted by Xi Jinping handling
two of China's most sensitive regions
mr. Chen had a track record he was party
boss in Tibet from 2011 to 2016 another
region where China wanted to crush
ethnic unrest he introduced a system of
pervasive and insidious control he
increased police presence stepped up the
communist propaganda campaign in
Buddhist temples and created a culture
of fear encouraging neighbors to spy on
one another now he has taken these
tested methods to Shenzhen
images of Xi Jinping have been placed in
some mosques and on-premise across the
province an act that offends religious
sensibilities beards and face veils have
been banned as have some halal products
this 800 year old mosque is one of many
that has been closed or bulldozed the
Weger language is banned in schools in
parts of Xinjiang Uighur heritage is
being wiped out it's a cultural genocide
is a very specific purpose systematic
method an ultimate goal that is to stamp
out Wever identity China is using
world-leading hyper surveillance
techniques in Xinjiang face recognition
cameras monitor week is on the streets
spy apps track them online my own family
have deleted me from their social media
connections imagine that you've missed
your mothers and fathers birthdays
because contacting them will endanger
their lives and may lead them to end up
in the camps
party informants even spy on Regas in
their own homes roughly half of
households are paired with a party
member who can drop in at any time
this official comes to their house gives
the children presents talks to them
about the wonders of Chinese communism
and of course reports back all sorts of
details are of interest to the
authorities if you stand in their way
we'll take you in a cab it's very clear
policy
many we gus' have been detained in camps
China has spent hundreds of millions of
dollars building at least 90 new
compounds like these people can be
imprisoned for many reasons or none at
all we don't quite know how many people
are in these camps but probably the
latest figures are at least a million
people are in camps now that's of the
order of one in six of the adult
population that's an enormous number
inside weekers are brainwashed they're
also reports of inmates being tortured
according to the survivors ik personal
account they forcing weavers to denounce
their religion you have to allow us to
convert you to be reformatted
reprogrammed to become just another Han
Chinese China's official line is that
the camps are designed to re-educate
extremists and fight terrorism but
there's another reason and it has to do
with China's ambitious economic project
known as the belt and Road initiative
William Chan with Utah
oh yeah they you know the tongue loosely
based on the historic Silk Road this
vast collection of infrastructure
projects seeks to connect China with
Africa and Europe this would
significantly expand China's economic
influence it spans over 70 countries and
will cost hundreds of billions of
dollars shinjang is sort of central to
Xi Jinping's grand project that project
is Xi Jinping's sort of signature
foreign policy and therefore Xinjiang is
so important to that that he just does
not want any trouble coming to our from
ginger
the weeds are victims of China's
determination to exercise complete
control over its population their future
is uncertain I don't want you to end up
in history books I want to live just
like anyone else and my people deserves
to live in this world with respect and
dignity